Hello everybody. I hope that you are
having a nice weekend. Bitcoin is really
not doing much because it's the weekend
and we also have the FOMC meeting on
Wednesday.
So the most likely thing is that we see
Bitcoin consolidating and ranging in
this zone until the FOMC meeting, okay?
So as I promised you guys, I think it's
time to chart some altcoins. And the
first one is going to be Chainlink
because I think the chart is looking
very interesting.
So if you guys would like me to chart
any other altcoin,
please let me know in the comments some
altcoins that you would like me to chart
for you.
Now, you have to keep in mind that this
video is going to be a bit different
because we're going to go with the
mindset of an investor that wants to buy
cheap and sell high or expensive in
higher time frame, okay? So it's kind of
like a preparation for the next bull
market.
That's what you have to keep in mind,
okay? We're going to stick to high time
frame, daily, weekly, monthly time
frame, and we're going to look for zones
of interest in the chart where you could
see the price of Chainlink heading to,
okay?
So the first thing to point out in this
chart is that we've been ranging here
for a year, okay? We started in this
range the 9th of May of '22. So now it's
basically 1 year of ranging here that it
seems that it's going to stay here
forever, but it will not. At some point
we'll break out, okay? So let's mark
this range, okay? I would say that this
is my low
Let me check and this should be my high
around here.
And you can see that well, this is the
middle of the range, okay? The Let me
mark it for you better.
Okay, that would be the middle of the
range and you can see that it's been
very easy to trade. It's basically buy
in this zone
and then sell
in this zone, okay? Simple. You can see
price goes again to the bottom of the
range, it bounces, and here you can get
a 75% what if you want to sell in the
middle of the range to be safe, that's a
13% happens again here. Well, in the
from the top you could you could go
short.
And that's another 20%.
We go again to the top.
20% in this zone goes to the bottom
again and you have two opportunities
to buy
33%
and here we have
another
50% okay? So, it's been pretty easy to
trade this so far. Basically, buy below
the middle of the range and sell at the
top of the range. Simple as that.
So, this has been a very nice zone for
swing traders especially, okay? For
trading this range. Now, if you're an
investor and you just want to buy and
hold
what are the good zones to buy? Well, I
think it's obvious that anything below
the middle of the range, so anything in
this zone here
is a good buy because I think we are now
around 90% down from at the highest. Let
me check.
Okay.
90%
Yes, we're 90% down from from the top.
So, if you're an investor and you
believe in the project, then this zone
here it's a good zone to buy. But, let's
go
a step forward and let's see if we could
buy cheaper.
We're still in the weekly time frame and
I think in my opinion that basically
what Chainlink is doing here is
retracing and recovering some imbalances
from that bull run in 2020, okay? You
can see this week
got retraced, another week retraced,
week retraced. And I think now the next
zone is this imbalance, this liquidity
pool, okay? And you can see this large
green candle that's already been
retraced, okay? Let me mark it for you.
Yeah, you can see that it's already
I think I would say a 50% of it has
already been retraced, but we still have
the other 50% that is this zone over
here.
What about if Chainlink wants to finish
this zone, okay? And make the move, you
know, we would also sweep the lows from
the range, you would have a beautiful
deviation.
And then if we bounce hard,
we could see breaking out from the top
of the range.
So, that's a plan that I have in mind,
okay? And trust me, at the moment, I
don't see Chainlink going lower than
this. It might, you know, it might go
all the way to this one over here.
Because yes, we have one more here.
Check this one.
That's around between three and two
dollars. Do I think it's going to go
there? I don't see that happening, to be
honest, because we've been ranging here
for a year. Bitcoin
dumped lower to 15k, and Chainlink
didn't lose that low.
Which is very interesting. But now,
well, I'm going to show you first that
chart with a correlation with Bitcoin.
Because Chainlink seems to do pretty
good in bear markets, and this This is
not the first time.
And also the Bitcoin dominance.
All right. Check this with me.
The orange line
is Bitcoin price action in the weekly
time frame, okay? Let me remove this.
And you can see that here, we have a low
that we were holding, okay? Same as
Link. We have a low here
that we were holding. But then Bitcoin
here lost that low, okay? This was the
FTX dump, okay? Lost that low and went
to 15k. Now, check what Link did.
You know, Link it was in this zone,
obviously dumped to following Bitcoin,
but didn't lose that low.
So, that's interesting, and that only
shows that Chainlink does pretty good in
bear markets, because, you know, if it
was a shitcoin or a weak asset, it would
just dump with Bitcoin and probably go
lower, like the rest of altcoins. So,
that's something pretty interesting.
If we check what happened previously in
the history of Link, you're going to see
something very similar, okay? That
happened right before this massive
impulsive move. Okay, this is uh
1,100%
move. This is insane, okay? So, what
happened here, if you notice,
you can see that Bitcoin in this zone,
you know, made a new low. Check this
first. Okay, we have a low
for LINK here. Let me mark it better
with this which is a straight line. We
have a low for Chainlink, a low for
Bitcoin. Then, Bitcoin zooms lower. You
can see that
Chainlink follows,
but it doesn't loses the low.
In fact, it makes a higher low. So,
that's, you know, it's happened before.
And then, look at what happened after.
A bit of consolidation.
You know, Bitcoin recovered in that
time, and then Bitcoin shoot up, and
Chainlink did the same.
So, keep that in mind,
because that's a bit of confluence to
the story that maybe we've already seen
the bottom for LINK. And if it's not the
bottom, I don't think it's going to be
further from this.
So, what I want to say with this,
of course, is not financial advice, but
I think that this zone over here
it's a good zone if for holders to buy.
And also, I don't think it's going to
get to this, you know, $3. I don't see
that happening, to be honest. Who knows?
Okay, I'll leave it from the chart for
now.
But who knows, okay?
And then, we have this zone that I find
very interesting that is between $5.25
and $4.72, okay? That zone it seems very
interesting also. If we go to the daily
time frame,
okay, let me check this.
Okay. So, you can see that in this zone,
it could be retested as support. Let me
check this.
Okay, that would be my high. Yeah, I
would say that this this was a
resistance back in time.
You can see that here it got it got
rejected, and then,
you know, tested as resistance,
sell-off.
Massive sell-off. That was the COVID
dump, by the way.
And then it comes again here, another
sell-off.
And then it It takes time to work around
it, but then it finally it breaks out,
okay? And if you notice in this zone
pretty much fits
with this liquidity pool that we've
marked, okay?
The blue zone.
And that's around 481.
So,
I'm We might see Chainlink going here.
If it goes here,
again, this is not financial advice, but
yes, I'll be becoming an an investor
probably and I'll put my money there at
481 zone. You know, in this blue zone,
this would be a great zone to buy
Chainlink, in my opinion.
So, after I've went through, you know,
the potential buy zones for Chainlink in
my that are my opinion, my personal
opinion that are good, okay? And I
repeat, it's not financial advice. You
guys do what you want. If you want to
buy now or never buy, that's up to you.
But that's just my opinion.
In my opinion, it would be, you know,
the bottom of the range and this
liquidity pool that matches with this
previous high, you know, that hasn't
been tested as support yet, around 480.
But now the question is, can Chainlink
go there again? Can Chainlink go, do you
know, to $6, to 525? Can it go to 480?
I'll let's start with the EMAs, okay? In
high time frame,
I like the 50 EMA
that you can see that it was tested as
resistance, and then we saw a big drop
here of I think this was a 20% Yeah, 20%
drop, okay?
So, that's important. If we go to the
monthly time frame, the same thing
happening. Look how many rejections
we're getting at the 50 EMA. So, that's
clearly a resistance, okay? I would
mark, if I was you, the 50 EMA in your
chart for Chainlink, okay? Let's go
again to the weekly time frame.
Let's see what happens in the daily.
In the daily, we are also below it,
okay? So, right now it's not looking
great, but who knows? Things can change
very quickly. But, the moment,
you know, as long as you are below the
EMAs,
it's going to push you down
in principle.
Now, there's another EMA that I like,
that's the 20 EMA. I like this in high
timeframe.
And you can see that in the weekly,
previously, it got rejected a lot of
times here, happened here, too. Here
again. Here, it happened four times. And
then here we have a very nice zone that
we were working out how to get above the
fifth double the 20 EMA, and we did, but
it got never tested as support
successful, okay?
So, then we have a problem.
Now, we just lost the 20 EMA. This is
the weekly timeframe. The weekly
candlestick closes tomorrow.
Okay?
And the monthly timeframe, too.
So, I mean, the monthly timeframe,
nothing nothing we can do about it
because it's clearly below the EMAs.
But, the weekly timeframe, if we close
below the 20 EMA again, like for
example, as it is as it is now,
in principle,
it should be pushing us lower, okay? We
could be seeing something like this.
So, that's the first thing telling me
that yes, we could see again lower
price. We could still see $6, $6.30,
$6.40.
Okay? You know, $4.80 is still far away.
We'll see what happens. But, that's
where I want to take you
to the Bitcoin dominance chart. Let's
have a look. The Bitcoin dominance chart
is a chart that is quite misunderstood,
I think, for what I see in Twitter.
Because people are only looking at this
zone, okay? That is, we've been in this
zone for 2 years.
So, when we get to these zones, okay, in
the chart, let me pull a
resistance line.
When we get to these zones, you see
traders calling for an alt season. And
let me tell you, this is not an old
season. This is not an old season. This
is not an old season.
These are only rallies because this is,
you know, let me let me show you the
bigger picture.
Okay? Let me zoom out.
Okay? Where are the lows?
This
is an old season. This is an old season.
You know, this is the 2020-2021
old season. You can see that was an old
season that everything was pumping. You
know, you could see your portfolio
doubling every day almost. It was crazy.
But these are not old seasons. These are
only rallies. That being said,
let's go back to this zone. We can see
that we are in a big range here. We've
been ranging here for 2 years.
Okay? This would be my low.
And that would be my high. Now, there
are two potential scenarios that might
play out in in here, okay? The first one
is that we stay in this range like we've
been for the past 2 years and that we
fall again to the bottom of the range.
That could be the first scenario.
But I got to admit that this candlestick
is looking pretty good. Look at this.
We're having a candle close with the
candle body
above the resistance, which is pretty
good. I mean, still we have here to
clean this one.
Not going to lie.
It's not everything happy at the moment
cuz we still have this resistance that
we got right here.
Okay?
This blue line. But you know, we have
never done this, you know, above this
white line having a candle body closing.
So,
what about
if we see
the Bitcoin dominance is starting to
break out to the upside, okay? Imagine
if we see something like this
happening.
Okay?
Now,
in the monthly time frame,
that's the 50 MA.
Could that happen? Tell me why not.
Tell me why we couldn't see that
happening, okay?
And would that be bad for altcoins?
Look, let me show you this chart. This
is cycle, okay? I'm sure you've seen
this this image many times before.
But basically,
you can see here that when the Bitcoin
dominance increases, okay, doesn't
matter what Bitcoin does,
alts either are going to continue
accumulating, you know, it's quite
stable price action, or decreasing, or
decreasing fast. So, it's not good for
alts coins if the Bitcoin dominance goes
up, simple as that. Now, if the Bitcoin
dominance decreases,
that's going to be good for alts coins,
no matter what Bitcoin does, in
principle.
Because in principle, the alts coins are
going to be stable, or are going to
increase, or they're going to increase
fast, which would be an an alt season,
okay?
So,
keep that in mind. And you can see that
obviously this video my my channel is
not promoted by any coin, so
if I was promoted by Chainlink, I would
tell you, "Yes, we're going to go to the
moon next month."
But I want to keep it realistic, okay? I
want to keep your feet in the ground.
There might be some pain still ahead, so
get ready for that.
Obviously, you know, you could always
DCA to not miss the move. You could
already start to buy at the bottom of
the range.
But I have very clear that I have a
plan.
First, I want to see how the Bitcoin
dominance goes. Well, if we start to see
something like this,
then we're going to see LINK
going lower.
Okay? And then yes, if that happens,
and Bitcoin also
Look, Bitcoin dominance increases,
Bitcoin decreases,
this could be for example like a retest
of the 25k zone that many analysts are
calling for. If they are right,
which they usually aren't,
but if are right this time and Bitcoin
starts to decrease and they go to the
25k zone,
then the altcoins are going to decrease
fast. We're going to see a big dump. And
then it's when you could see
getting touched.
So, that being said, okay?
It's difficult to tell
where Chainlink could go to the upside.
But, I mean, if we have been
accumulating for a year, obviously, the
breakout is going to be quite intense.
And we're going to start to expect some
higher prices. Where to? Well, we're
going to start to notice the imbalances.
We'll have this one, for example, here.
That is 13 zone. And I'm noticing that I
think it matches with Yeah, it matches
with this week over here, okay? So,
that's pretty interesting. That's the
first zone where we could be taking
profits.
This is a a a different one. Look,
another liquidity pool. This is around
18 15. And then, of course, we have this
big boy over here. This massive
imbalance
between 20
and 25. So, that's pretty much all of
it, guys.
But, before I close the video, I want to
repeat that, you know, this is not
financial advice. It's my personal
opinion, my own analysis. You might have
a different one.
And it may be different from mine, and
that's the beautiful thing about
charting, that we might have different
opinions.
But, I think it's always good to be
prepared for both the scenarios.
You know, this might shoot up from here,
or it might drop lower to 480, or again
to range lows again. Why not? You must
be prepared for both scenarios.
That's the only way to trade. That's the
only way to stay in the game. So, that's
why I think you should also keep an eye
on the Bitcoin dominance chart,
and also in the 50-week EMA. Sorry, in
the 50-20 EMA.
Let's see how this week closes.
If it closes below it, we'll be favoring
lower prices in the short term at least.
But if it closes above it, then we're
going to start to see
some kind of consolidation again
between the 20 and the 50.
And then maybe the 20 starts to point
upwards.
And the 50 crosses.
And then we're going to start to see
something like this, okay?
But for now,
it's impossible to tell. We must only be
prepared for both scenarios. And then
guys, at least I hope that I entertained
you. Thank you for watching.
And I'll see you soon.